your grace grace and if you fall don't
scream you don't want that to be the
last thing she remembers just see if you
can take a hit lad
it's prettier than both my daughters
they think you some kind of God I'm not
God I know I saw your pecker what kind
of God would have a pack of that small I
know what mounted Knights can do to us
you and Stannis cut through us like piss
through snow
we're digging trenches all along our
flanks they won't be able to hit it the
way that's done is hit you and a double
envelopment a pincer move they won't be
able to hit this from the sides good
closest castle to hardhome is
eastwatch-by-the-sea and that's where
I'll go looks like we're the Nights
Watch now how many queens are there now
too and you need to convince the one
with the dragons or the one who [ __ ]
her brother both I'm an amended you
bring know enough the people move I can
breathe again down south the air smells
like the big [ __ ] you've never been down
south I've been to Winterfell
that's the north smart people don't come
up here
looking for the dead
we lost you almost is little but he's
strong
most people get bloody murdered they
stay that way not this one I didn't I'm
not saying that
yeah you're not gonna ride the dragon
south Greg girl needs to heal he doesn't
need me wearing him down you weigh as
much as two fleas [ __ ] I'm taking the
free folk home we've had enough of the
south this is the north you know